[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio more
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internationale
en colaboración con la televisión
france24 en español en la que cada
semana damos la palabra a artistas
políticos gente del mundo de los
deportes de la ciencia de las artes y de
la sociedad civil dos países en el mundo
tienen el privilegio que su cocina sea
reconocida como patrimonio cultural
inmaterial de la humanidad por la unesco
la organización de las naciones unidas
para la educación la ciencia y la
cultura
hablamos de francia y méxico la primera
por su saber en su gastronomía en el
caso de méxico por sus prácticas
culturales y el saber tradicional de su
cocina hoy vamos a hablar de gastronomía
mexicana y nos acompaña precisamente en
este estudio el chef mexicano otoniel
álvarez castañeda otoniel bienvenido a
esta escala en parís variable muchas
gracias por invitación un placer tenerlo
con nosotros la cocina mexicana vuelve
estar de honores aquí en francia con
motivo del séptimo salón de lo que se
les llama qué gusto que se dedica
precisamente a las cocinas del mundo en
este caso está centrada en el estado de
veracruz para que nuestro público puede
entender un poco geografía un poco de
elementos que es el estado de veracruz
el estado de veracruz situado en el
golfo de méxico una costa una costa del
golfo de méxico un territorio hace
extenso donde bueno es un es uno de
nuestros de nuestros puertos y que hace
conexión internacional comercialmente al
internacional nacional de entrada para
los españoles así es un puerto dónde
llegaron muchas culturas tanto de europa
como de áfrica de mismo de américa
latina una puerta de la entrada de
nuestro territorio a nuestro territorio
pues vamos a ver con detalle
precisamente por qué es importante este
estado de veracruz para la cocina
mexicana en sheffield otoniel usted
nació en méxico viaja a francia ha hecho
sus estudios acá entre otras cosas hoy
trabaja como chef independiente un
recorrido muy rápido de manera muy breve
un poco de biografía de su historia como
chef así es yo nací en tenancingo estado
de méxico
vengo a francia a realmente al finalizar
mis estudios en gastronomía y hotelería
megawatts para trabajar un poco aprendo
sobre la cocina mis primeros pasos
realmente en
el
medio de la gastronomía mis primeros
pasos fueron la cocina japonesa donde
aprendo mucho sobre la cocina japonesa
[Música]
típica japonesa y bueno vamos siendo
también parte de el programa de cambiar
un poco la rutina y por qué no adquirir
o implementar la cocina japonesa a la
mexicana y la francesa hace una función
importante es sumamente interesante para
mí también poder tener este esta
experiencia me ha robado la pregunta
escribe yo soy precisamente cómo se hace
esa fusión entre tres cocinas tan
conocidas tan reputadas
internacionalmente a veces con la
delicadeza de los productos a veces con
ese con ese maridaje que podemos darle a
ciertos a ciertos platillos que pueden
entrar allí a ciertos productos o
japoneses o franceses o mexicanos vamos
realmente a experimentar una fusión y
una explosión de sabores que es
sumamente interesante yo foto bien
hablamos de entonces que es el estado de
veracruz el invitado de honor en este
nuevo festival de qué gusto veracruz es
conocido por una gran cantidad de cosas
notablemente la vainilla que viene de la
ciudad de papantla conocido mundialmente
que se produce en una serie de
en el mundo por su reputado café café de
altura coatepec pero no solo que otros
platos que otros elementos de la
gastronomía veracruzana podría darnos
con un ejemplo pues bueno veracruz es un
es un es un productor muy importante
también la caña de azúcar no hay que
olvidarlo en la extensión realmente de
los platillos de caña de azúcar es muy
importante los planteos de la piña
también como un productor también muy
importante en cuanto a cítricos naranjas
y limones y bueno y de igual forma vamos
a encontrar todas las preparaciones
culinarias realmente de este de este
estado o el mole vamos a vamos a
encontrar unos moldes de plátano macho
sabes o sea realmente es un es un estado
de veracruz tiene hoy en día una
gastronomía tan extensa que a veces no
está tan valorizada es por eso también
uno de los puntos más importantes porque
hoy vamos a hacer la esta edición de
festiva qué gusto que va a estar
inspirada en el estado de veracruz
realmente para darle ese impacto de la
cultura gastronómica que tiene el estado
de veracruz que no está tan tan
explotada y que conocemos muy pocos a
darle realmente ese empuje esfuerzo que
esta edición se hace en torno al estado
de veracruz bastante interesante y para
aquellos que no conocen méxico cuando
conocen el estado de veracruz que se
encuentra sobre el golfo de méxico sepan
que tiene ni más ni menos que 720
kilómetros de costa esto le da una gran
capacidad en términos de producción de
mariscos de texas del mar de pesca está
el famoso pescado verá pulsando en
vertical salsas y sigue otoniel digamos
que la gastronomía francesa y la cocina
mexicana son sus dos amores
como lleva esto a cabo pues que en uno
no sea tan celosa que la otra porque
realmente si son y dos amores la cocina
francesa tenemos la cocina francesa
realmente la conocemos mundialmente como
la los franceses como una cuna de la
referencia a media una referencia serial
exactamente pero una que olvidar que la
cocina también mexicana ahorita también
ya está es parte de dell unesco y
obviamente tenemos muchísimas cosas esa
similitud
también de platillos por la polis
intercambio de culturas pero también
tenemos una una extensa variedad de
cosas gastronómicas en nuestro país que
nunca vamos a terminar realmente de
descubrirlo todo justamente como toda
cocina que se respeta por un lado está
la tradición pero por otro lado requiere
evolucionar adaptarse
mezclar nuevos gustos sabores
descubrimientos cómo llegó usted a cabo
ese desafío que es un desafío al final
de cuentas permanente así es y no es
fácil no es fácil es realmente hacerla
evolucionar o hacerla funcionar hay que
encontrar el medio equilibrio realmente
para poder llevar a cabo los dos una
cocina tradicional se tiene que respetar
100% a lo mejor pues las técnicas las
técnicas los ingredientes los métodos de
preparación tendrían que ser los justos
innecesarios pero también lo moderno
entonces a que realmente cuando hacemos
este tipo de cosas hay que es es
delicado y hay que encontrar realmente
el punto medio para que sea bueno para
que tenga también un impacto favorable
hacia hace el cliente o hacia nuestros
invitados
pero es también muy excitante el poder
el poder crear el poder hacer un chef
como usted preparando platillos antes de
ofrecérselos a los comensales se
equivocan mucho así es así que hay que
pasar por la prueba del error exacto
sucesivamente exacto tenemos tenemos que
ensayar siempre tenemos que probar
tenemos que hacer que las cosas resulten
resulten y como que como entienden como
tengan que resultar hubo muchos errores
durante la gastronomía que hoy en día
conocemos que hoy en día son platillos
tradicionales son preparaciones
culinarias de base que surgieron de
errores
otoniel álvarez como hacen ustedes
sabiendo que de hecho la gastronomía la
cocina se ha vuelto también un gran
negocio un enorme negocio mundial si
sabemos que se abren escuelas por el
tiempo hay las emisiones en televisión
en radio hay miles de gentes que se
interesan precisamente en llegar a ser
jefe o sueñan con ser un alto ser de
phishing pero como hacen ustedes para
evitar caer en s
de esa trampa vamos a decirlo así y al
mismo tiempo permitirle a esa gente que
se interesa pues poder integrar ese
mundo que finalmente es un poco selecto
así es eso es
la gastronomía realmente hacer parte de
hacer estudios en gastronomía realmente
no es para todo el mundo si es una
disciplina muy rigurosa es una
disciplina que hay que hay que tratarla
también con respeto y como tú decías no
hay que caer en esa en esa trampa si
queremos hacer un negocio podemos hacer
negocios de diferente forma pero
realmente la gastronomía o la cocina hay
que respetar el producto hay que saber
respetar este las temporadas también
porque porque hoy en día también estamos
viviendo otro tipo de situaciones en las
que nos va a ser muchísimo más difícil
poder alimentarnos es un negocio porque
porque obviamente todo ser humano
requiere una alimentación y que mejor
que con algo algo muy bueno y rico sin
duda alguna deseamos usted ha venido
para participar en esto que fue el
festival qué gusto que les ofreció a sus
comensales
algunos platillos seleccionados de esa
cocina veracruzana exacto esta es en
esta ocasión vamos tenemos platillos muy
seleccionados que van a ser parte para
nuestra presentación y mi mapa y mi
participación en el festival productos
muy típicos del estado de veracruz por
ejemplo en una inflada de piloncillo
explicar a la gente un poco que quiere
decir su inflado y leslie frazier no
sólo sobre imaginen que lo puedan
también saborear así es de life light el
piloncillo conoce el piloncillo el
piloncillo es la primera extracción de
la de la crianza así es y ya está
gordita pues eso realmente una una
tortilla espesa de maíz de maíz
nixtamalizado que la vamos a cocer por
dos lados en seco en un comal y luego la
vamos a meter a una freidora con aceite
muy caliente y el vapor que se va a
generar dentro de estas dos costas es lo
que va a permitir que se infle y
obviamente el sabor tiene ese sabor a
piloncillo porque porque nuestro maíz lo
vamos a mezclar con el piloncillo le
vamos a raspar un poquito de piloncillo
lo vamos a hidratar con un té también de
anís entonces realmente la
unam
es un plato muy típico del estado de
veracruz decíamos en principio son dos
las cocinas que hasta el día de hoy han
sido reconocidas por la unesco como
patrimonio inmaterial de la humanidad la
cocina francesa la cocina mexicana pero
sin duda yo imagino que usted piensa
como yo como mucha gente que podría
haber muchas otras cocinas que podrían
hacer parte de ese selecto grupo de
países pienso por ejemplo en la cocina
china pienso en la cocina hindú pienso
por ejemplo en la cocina peruana en la
cocina colombiana si usted tuviese que
elegir otro país otro tipo de cocina que
pudiese hacer parte de ese podium donde
están hoy solo francia y méxico en que
cocina pensaría y por qué razón
creo que es difícil
escoger
escoger otra vez pero también hay una
cocina que me tiene aquí que yo la tengo
también ahorita dentro de mis de mis
pensamientos en la cocina
tailandesa compartimos también varias
cosas parecen otros las cosas del
picante así es así es el trabajo que
ellos hacen para su uso su picante como
también lo trabajan para que sea menos
picante es algo muy interesante como
iguales en
ejemplo mi amigo mi abuela con la que yo
aprendí realmente a cocinar ella para
que no aplicará tanto el chile lo lavaba
lo acariciaban los agaves esto también
con azúcar no se llamaba así es muy bien
rápidamente otoniel cómo hacer para
mantener el nivel de rigor que se
requiere en la alta cocina y al mismo
tiempo permitir que la gente de escasos
recursos que no tiene mucho para pagarse
un restaurant muy muy caro puede
aprovechar precisamente esos manjares
que son tan suculentos de manera breve
por favor yo creo que es ya que hay que
seguir siendo humildes hay que tenerlos
press de los pies realmente bien soy
sobre la tierra yo creo que con humildad
todos del mundo podemos avanzar y
tenemos que ser también constantes pues
como todo buen platillo como todo buen
manjar estamos llegando ya al final de
este programa no me queda sino
agradecerle al set mexicano
otoniel álvarez su presencia en nuestros
estudios gracias por habernos acompañado
en nuestro el apetito a ustedes les
damos una nueva cita aquí la próxima
semana en otra escala en parís gracias
por su atención
[Música]